Every once in a
while I like a good old Pat Robertson story.
And since it's Christmas time or something,
I thought that we would do one today.
So televangelists Pat Robertson is known for
his online Christianity show.
I don't know what else to call it, the 700
club.
He's now 89 years old.
He's doing a show.
He continues to do his show.
He's been doing it a very, very long time.
And he has often said, Oh, God told me this.
God told me that God told me.
The other thing.
God apparently speaks to Pat Robertson regularly
and, uh, Pat Robertson, thanks to his conversations
with God, even if they are one way conversations,
maybe.
Um, there are many things that Pat Robertson
has learned are demonic.
So in the past, over the last 10 years, we've
heard from Pat Robertson that secondhand sweaters
from Goodwill are a, can be demonic Weegee
boards and yoga can be demonic.
Harry Potter and Fang SJ way are definitely
demonic.
Karate horoscopes can have demons attached.
The Twilight series, very demonic paintings
of Buddha.
Absolutely demonic TV shows about ghosts are
demonic.
Halloween is, I mean who of course that's
Psychics are demonic.
Young girls who levitate their friends at
sleep overs and even sometimes adopted children
from other countries can come with demons
attached according to Pat Robertson.
Now it seems as though God may have played
a bit of a dirty trick on Pat Robertson because
for a very long time now, Pat Robertson has
been assuring his audience that, don't worry,
Donald Trump is not going to get impeached
by the house of representatives.
It won't happen.
No way.
No how it seems that Pat Robertson was let
us stray, may be by what he heard from God
during prayer.
Take a look at one of a few examples of Pat
Robertson predicting there will be no impeachment.
The house will not vote impeachment.
There will be no impeachment.
They don't have the courage to do it.
Then there is no way that they will be.
There'll be a majority vote in the United
States house of representatives to bring forth
a bill of impeachment.
If you then go to the Senate and so forth,
and my prediction is that Eaton going to happen.
They will not have a vote.
They will be no impeachment and we'll go forward
to the election.
I don't believe there will be an a peach mode
boat.
As I said before, I'll say it again.
There is not going to be an impeachment vote
in the house.
That really puts everybody on record.
Well, here's my fair Fair's prediction.
One more time.
The house does not have the guts to vote impeachment.
They will not vote in patient.
They will not vote it.
They just Mark my word.
They do not have the courage to go for the
American people.
This is all a publicity stunt.
Ladies, you don't, I've said it before.
I'll say it again.
There is no way that these Democrats were
there to vote impeachment to motor village
and pavement for
such a religious man who takes all of his
problems, questions and inquiries to God.
It's shocking.
He was so wrong on this in a sense, isn't
it?
And this actually reminded me of, so I dunno
if people remember, but years ago when producer
Louis was still producer, we brought in a
psychic and had her do a live reading of Lewis
and have me a cold reading, I guess we would
call it.
And it was just a fiasco.
And of course, um, there were those, uh, including
Louis, I think, who said, even though psychics
are real, that was not a real psychic or whatever.
And after that, even though I announced we're
not doing anymore of this, I, uh, started
getting emails from so-called psychics saying,
Hey, David, I want to go on and prove to you
that psychics are real and that I'm a real
psychic.
And every time I've said to them, if you're
a psychic, shouldn't you already have known
in advance that I wasn't going to have you
on my show and you could have skipped emailing
me altogether.
And every single time they say the same thing,
that's not how it works.
There always has to be some mystery about
how it works.
And it's often that way with Pat Robertson.
Either God works in mysterious ways or maybe
Pat Robertson didn't pray hard enough for
the right answers from God or something like
that.
But in any case, there it is.
Pat Robertson apparently not quite as good
at political prophecy.
Well actually I don't know that he's that
good at any prophecy really.
But apparently Pat, Pat Robertson just not
that good at making predictions.
And if you just to kind of bring this around
because it's been so long since we talked
about Pat, a lot of people probably aren't
familiar, particularly our younger viewers
and listeners, uh, with how Pat Robertson
got started and built up this 700 club thing.
He started it on the, from what I recall,
con early contributions of a bunch of people
that he knew personally, friends, acquaintances,
whatever, and grew the 700 club into a evangelical
Christian institution with an incredible backstory
that I am not pleased by.
I don't like it.
I don't think it's a good show for humanity.
But it is an interesting story nonetheless.
And I encourage you to check it out.
Probably the 700 club Wiki or the Wiki about
Pat Robertson would have a the story, check
it out.
It is both interesting, compelling and scary
all at the same time.